The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: So
I am Cathy Drennan.
You're going to be
learning more about me
as this morning goes on.
Everybody should have a handout.
If you do not have
a handout, Aaron
will come around
and give you one
if you just raise your hand.
There's a few in the
back that just came in.
We will be giving out-- look
for TAs as you come in the room.
We'll have handouts for you
every day so look for them.
And if you come in late
we'll normally leave them
in the entrance way here.
I know that some of you have
a long walk between classes,
so the handouts
will be available.
So when you come in, grab your
handout and come on into class.
So now, let me tell you a little
more about these things lecture
notes that you can bring a pen
or pencil to class to write on.
So this is the
summary for today.
So today is really more
about announcements and what
we're going to cover, but
there are some features
of today's handouts that you
can use throughout the semester.
So lecture summaries
will always have
the reading for the class
for that day's class.
So when you're going back over
things and thinking about it,
you can always look
at what reading
was associated with the class.
They'll also always have a
reading for the next class,
so you can read
ahead which is good
for the pre-lecture questions.
So now I want to give you
a sense of the material.
So we had this on our
list of topics today.
General information.
We've gone through
course material overview
and introductions to
the teaching team,
but it's MIT so we need
to start with a quiz.
The quizzes.
Can you tell me who
these people are?
So who is This
AUDIENCE: you.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: It is me.
This is my college
yearbook picture.
So one day you will
have one of these.
Who is this?
AUDIENCE: It's you.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: It's not me.
People say that, but thank you.
It is Lisa Kudrow.
So who knows who Lisa Kudrow is?
Friends, yes.
So Lisa Kudrow and
I were classmates.
We were in the same year.
So you can look at
who's next to you
and figure out
who in your row is
going to be that famous person
that one day you can say, yes,
I was classmates with them.
So Lisa and I were classmates.
What do you think Lisa
went to college to study?
I heard the correct
answer out there.
It was in fact biology.
What do you think I went
to college to study?
Yes, some people have
watched my OpenCourseWare
and know these things.
Yes, theater, drama,
biopsychology.
That's kind of like course nine.
That's what I was interested in.
What do you think
Lisa majored in?
AUDIENCE: Bio.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Biology?
Or drama?
It was biology.
What do you think I majored in?
It was chemistry.
And of course, we all know
that Lisa is an actress
and I am a chemistry professor.
So I like to start
every class with this
because I think it says
something very important.
I did not like chemistry
in high school.
I was in chorus.
I would schedule every
one of my music lessons
during the chemistry class.
I did everything to avoid
having to attend chemistry
in high school, and
then I went to college
and they said you have to take
chemistry if you're thinking
of a biopsychology major.
And I was like, I've
taken chemistry.
I'm quite convinced
chemistry is not
relevant to biology in any way.
I was told I was wrong.
I was sure I was right.
I took chemistry and
realized that chemistry
can be very different in
different circumstances
and that everybody can
find their appreciation
for chemistry at a different
time in their lives.
Some of you right now
already like chemistry,
but a lot of you
probably have not
found your love
for chemistry yet.
Some of you may find
that love for chemistry
during this semester.
I'm hoping it'll be a
large fraction of you.
Some of you may not find
your love for chemistry
until next year or senior
year at MIT or even
in graduate school or even
when you have a job later on.
Sometimes when I'm traveling
around-- and as a professor
I travel the world
and give talks
and I'm chatting with
someone in an airplane
or on a bus or something and
they say, what do you do?
And then I say, oh,
I teach chemistry.
And I always kind of watch
the reaction to that.
And some of them are
like, uh, chemistry,
and other people say,
boy, I'm an engineer now
and I have to work with
chemists all the time
and I really wish I had paid
more attention in chemistry
class because we
need to work together
and I need to understand
more what they're doing.
So some people do not find
their love or their appreciation
for chemistry until they
have a career later in life.
So I'm not sure when it's
going to be for all of you,
but if you have
not found it yet I
am hoping to find a connection--
your connection to chemistry.
What about chemistry
relates to what
you want to do in the future?
And one reason that I did
not appreciate chemistry
in high school is
I didn't really
understand who chemists
were and I didn't really
understand what chemistry was.
What people used chemistry for.
And part of the reason I
think were these pictures
that are often shown in
intro courses for chemistry
and in your intro textbooks.
That's partly why I
think $8 is a good price
to spend on these
chemistry textbooks.
These are great chemists
but they're all dead,
and that really gives the
message that chemistry
is not a living discipline.
Chemistry was a thing
that people used to do
and it was exciting
at that time,
but then when they got
rid of their powdered wigs
they moved on to other fields.
So I'm going to be showing
you some different pictures
in this class.
I'm going to be showing
you these pictures.
Some of the old pictures
will be there too,
but every time I show
you a dead white guy
I want to show you
someone who is alive.
So these are living chemists.
People who are using chemistry
every day of their lives,
and I'm going to be showing
short videos of these people
telling you how
they're using chemistry
and what chemistry is
being used for today.
So you'll be hearing-- and
this is a series I like call
in their own words.
Another thing that I didn't
appreciate about chemistry
was in the lab course I had
a strong base and a weak acid
and we would drop,
drop, drop, drop,
drop until it turned pink.
And then we could calculate
the molecular weight
of an unknown weak acid.
And I ask myself, is this
like a real pressing problem?
A lot of weak acids out there
somewhere that if only we
knew the molecular weight
the problems of the world
would be solved?
But it turns out that this
is kind of a good intro lab,
but it's in fact not what
chemists do every day.
We will learn about
titrations because we
need to know PKA because
PKA is important,
but we don't have a
lab and we're not going
to be doing that experiment.
So what is chemistry research?
Chemistry research is all
of these following things.
So creating quantum dots
to be used in surgery.
How do you know if
the doctor's got
the right amount of a tumor?
You don't want to
take more flesh
than you need but you don't
want to miss some of the cancer.
So you want to image exactly
where that cancer is.
Chemistry is designing
sensors to find explosives
in war zones.
This is a really important
problem right now.
Biofuels, energy,
alternative energy--
that's what chemistry is.
Using basic principles
to figure out
how to design better biofuels.
Or making new pharmaceuticals.
We haven't really
produced new antibiotics
in a long time in this
country, and a lot
of things that we thought used
to be treatable conditions
now are no longer so
treatable because we
don't have new antibiotics
and the bugs are becoming
resistant to the old ones.
This is what chemistry
research is today.
This is what you're going to be
using chemical principles for.
So what chemical
principles are you
going to be learning that will
help you solve these real world
problems?
So we need to learn
about matter and we
need to know how matter reacts.
So in the first
half of the course
we're going to start
with atomic theory.
There is going to be a
little bit of history
involved in that.
Talking about the discovery
of the nucleus, electrons,
protons.
And so we're going to have
a little bit of history
and some cool demos.
We're going to move on
to the periodic table.
That's the chemist toolbox.
Those are the elements that
we can combine to make things,
and when we combine them to
make things they need to bond
so we're going to
talk about bonding.
And they're going
to form molecules,
and we need to think about the
structures of those molecules
because the structures
dictate the properties
of those molecules
of that matter.
And then molecules can react.
So we're going to talk
about how they react,
and whether a reaction is going
to go is about thermodynamics.
Is it going to be spontaneous?
But then, we also need to know
if it's faster or if it's slow.
That's kinetics.
So we're going to cover
both of those things.
Chemical equilibrium.
You can have a reaction
that goes one way
and is going in the reverse
direction at the same time.
And there'll be an equilibrium
constant associated
with that reaction,
but sometimes
you really want to go more
in the forward direction
to make the thing
you want to make.
So you need to think about
how the reaction quotient
queue is related to the
equilibrium constant K.
And if you're the Green
Lantern, equilibrium constants
are meaningless.
You have the Green
Lantern ring and you
can push that equilibrium in
any direction that you want.
If you're the Green Lantern,
Q is always greater than K.
But if you're a
student of chemistry,
you actually can
become a super hero
by learning about those
chemical principles.
And then, you can drive Q to
be greater than K as well.
So I want to teach you
how to be a super hero.
I also am going to teach you
about solubility and acid base
and oxidation
reduction reactions
because those are really the
fundamental types of reactions
that occur in biology, in
materials, and everything.
And a little unit on
transition metals.
That middle part of
the periodic table
where you have iron and
cobalt and copper and nickel
and all those
amazing elements that
really allow you to do the most
challenging chemical reactions.
Those are especially
fun, and if you
want to have the
power of chemistry
you've got to know about
the transition metals.
So without chemistry
you wouldn't be alive.
Your body are a series
of chemical reactions.
You wouldn't be wearing the
clothes that you're wearing.
Pretty much a
chemist figured out
the material that you're wearing
and or how to process it.
And I think really importantly,
you couldn't spell MIT without.
Chemistry
We have the M from
physics, the I for math,
and we have the
T from chemistry.
So if you want to
spell MIT you gotta
learn about the ideal gas law.
And you wouldn't have the paper
that you might be currently
writing on without chemistry.
So you really should
study chemistry
because the major
challenges of our time
require chemistry
knowledge to fix them.
Treating human disease requires
an understanding of chemistry.
Solving the energy problem
requires an understanding
of chemistry.
And I believe people will come
up with alternative energy.
I'm just less convinced
that they're not
going to destroy the
environment while they do it.
So I really think we
need people thinking
about solving the energy problem
who care about the environment
and can use chemistry
to think about how
we can protect the environment.
So why do I care
so much about this?
And that's because
yesterday morning I
walked my daughter to her
first day of first grade.
She's six years old.
She's starting
school, and I need
people to know chemistry
to make the world a better
place for her.
So what I can do as a
mother who's a chemist
is find the smartest people
I can find, which I've done,
and then teach them
the chemical principles
they know to make the world a
better place for my daughter.
So what I'm hoping
that you will do here
in my course objectives-- I
said I'd get back to these.
I want you to have a working
knowledge of chemistry
that you can take
advanced courses.
Starting pretty simple.
That's what I want.
I also want you to
know enough chemistry
so you can do a UROP
in a chemistry lab,
and we'll talk more about
the undergraduate research
program throughout the course.
I would like you to employ
chemistry principals
in a lab that's not a
chemistry lab in your UROP.
I want you to
appreciate how chemistry
is used to solve
real world problems,
to make informed decisions
about your health, about
the environment, and
energy and science policy,
and I want you to be able to
advance science and engineering
through the application
of chemistry principles
because I want you to
make the world a better
place for my daughter.
And that's why I want you all
to have superior knowledge
because my daughter needs
more than adequate knowledge
to have a better world.
She needs superior knowledge.
So that's my goal
for all of you.
To teach you these things.
You don't all have
to become chemists.
In fact, it's fantastic if you
take the knowledge of chemistry
and bring it to
other disciplines
because we're going to need all
the disciplines coming together
with that solid knowledge to
be able to make this world
a better place.
I'll say that there are
many 5.111 superstars
in this class in the
past who came in,
like Sarah who hated chemistry
and became a chem major
and ended up getting a
PhD in chemical biology.
All these folks have
gone on using chemistry,
not all as chemists-- in
biological engineering,
full ride scholarship to
medical school, PhD in biology,
running a local pharmaceutical
company as an executive,
doing biophysics out at UCSF.
So all of these people
learned the chemistry
they needed to go on
and do great things,
and you can put your
picture in there.
So speaking of people,
we have five minutes
where I really need to introduce
you to all the teaching team.
We have a huge
group of people who
are going to make
it possible for you
to obtain that superior
knowledge of chemistry
and go on here at MIT
to do great things.
So I'm going to ask
them all to come down.
And I think we have
a hand-held mic.
And everyone can
introduce themselves.
And let's bring that down.
Actually, maybe
we'll start here.
ELENA GORIN: Hi everybody.
My name is Elena Gorin.
I'm going to be your course
coordinator for this semester.
So if you have any
issues that you
feel need to be
handled by someone
closer to Professor
Drennan I'm the one.
I'll also be sending a lot
of e-mails to you guys,
so pay attention.
And I'll tell you a
little bit about clickers.
You'll get an e-mail from
me about clickers very soon.
SAM: Hi, everyone.
My name is Sam.
I am the clicker TA, so I'll be
handling clickers and clicker
competitions and
stuff like that.
So if you have any
clicker questions
you can find me before or after
class in the clicker corner
I think is what
I'm designating it.
Clicker corner.
So if you forget your
clicker or anything
like that-- I encourage
you not to forget them,
but if you happen
to don't panic.
Just come see me and
we'll work things out.
And we're supposed
to say something
that I enjoy doing outside of
chemistry in graduate school.
So I ski.
So if there are any
skiers in the audience,
we should hang out.
ASHLEY: Hi, everyone.
My name is Ashley.
I'll be running
recitation number eight,
so I look forward to
meeting as many of you
as I'll have the
opportunity to meet.
One of the things that I
enjoy outside of chemistry
is Latin dance.
I'm not saying I'm any good
at it, but I do try to be.
YIVAN Hi, I'm Yivan.
I run the microphone.
Me and Ashley run
the microphone,
so we'll run around, give it to
you whenever you have questions
during class.
I run recitation
four and I enjoy
cycling outside of chemistry.
AARON: Hi, I'm Aaron.
I'm one of the two handout TAs.
So before class you want to
make sure you have a handout
before you get into the class.
So Toe and I and probably a
few other people on some days
will be making sure
you all get handouts
before you get in class.
I'll be running
recitation two, so I
will hope we'll see 25 of
you or so at 2:00 tomorrow.
And outside of class, I
enjoy doing taekwondo.
ODIN: I'm Odin.
I was lucky enough to be
switched into this class just
yesterday, actually.
And I enjoy hiking.
I spent a lot of time
in the White Mountains
up in New Hampshire.
DAN: Hi, I'm Dan.
I'm in recitation seven, so
hopefully I'll see some of you
guys tomorrow.
It's at 12 o'clock.
And outside of
chemistry-- I guess
some of my favorite
things to do are just
play pick up games of soccer
or football with my friends.
MIKE: Hi, I'm Mike.
I'm the MITx coordinator
for the class,
so if you have questions
about pre-lecture questions
talk to me.
I was also the graduate
chemistry teacher here
for the last couple of
years in quantum mechanics,
so I'll have office hours
on Wednesdays after class.
So if you have quantum mechanics
questions come and ask me.
LISA: Hi, I'm LIsa.
I'm teaching the recitation
six, so if you're in six
you're with me.
It's going to be awesome.
I enjoy traveling and running.
So usually what I like
to do is every time
I go to a new place I like
to go for a run there.
It's kind of weird, but.
ROSE: Hi, my name is Rose.
I'll be teaching
recitation number nine.
Outside of chemistry
and school I
enjoy reading and being outside.
I go for runs too.
ERIC ALT: Hi, I'm
Eric Alt. I think
I'm teaching recitation five.
And outside of chemistry
I like to run and play
soccer and other sports.
FRANK: Hi, my name
is Frank and I'm not
teaching any
recitation, but I will
be the Pset TA for the course.
And what I love to do outside
class was playing badminton.
THO: Hi, I'm Tho,
like toes right here.
Seriously.
I'm teaching rescission number
11, and outside of chemistry
I have no interest so I just
sit there and do nothing.
ANTHONY: Hi, I'm Anthony.
I teach recitation
section number one.
Bright and early
at 10am tomorrow.
Outside of chemistry I enjoyed
tennis and playing piano.
ERIC: Hi, my name is Eric
and I teach recitation 10.
And outside of chemistry
I like to cook.
AMANDA: Hi, I'm Amanda.
I don't remember my
recitation number
but I know it's at 2
o'clock in the afternoon,
so maybe I'll see
some of you tomorrow.
And when I'm not doing
chemistry or school
I like to ride horses.
I grew up on a horse farm.
JAY: Hi, everybody.
I'm Jay.
I'm doing recitation
number three.
It's at 3pm tomorrow.
Hopefully I'll see
some of you guys there.
Me and Eric are
the two demo TAs.
So when we have awesome demos
in class you can thank us.
And outside of chemistry I like
to play tennis and table tennis
too.